for 300 years the targaryen dynasty
stayed strong
in the face of rebellion civil war and
plague
but the line of dragon kings was broken
when my father
aries targaryen the second of his name
was overthrown
in rebellion my father was betrayed
and slaughtered by sir jaime lannister a
member of his own kingsguard
his son and heir my brother rhaegar
perished on the field of battle at the
hands of robert baratheon
who claimed the iron throne for himself
[Music]
ours is the fury these are the words of
the black stag of baratheon
a battle cry echoed throughout the land
in rebellion when i
robert baratheon the first of his name
seized the iron throne from the mad
king aerys targaryen ending a dynasty
nearly 300 years old
after aegon's conquest of the seven
kingdoms the baratheons remained loyal
enough to the crown while targaryen
kings
came and went but loyalty has its limits
when rhaegar targaryen harris's vile
son and heir abducted lyanna stark
i betrothed my beloved
it was time to act we raised our banners
baratheon stark john aaron and the
tullys
united in rebellion against rhaegar and
his father the mad king
we were victorious and took the iron
throne
that bit of dragon blood in my veins
came in well
as it made me a distant relation to the
targaryen dynasty blood of my long
lost ancestor oris the truth of it is
i took it under the targaryens the
riverlands knew a piece we hadn't had
for centuries
if ever but like all good things
sooner or later it all goes to
and our had a name
aries targaryen
westeros has had its share of mad kings
but usually they have the sense not to
bully more than one powerful house at a
time
aries soon blundered into a triple
alliance
the north stormlands and vale rose
against him
but of course where do you think most of
the blood was spilled
my brother hoster guaranteed the answer
to that with a marriage of my niece to
eddard stark
the warden of the north at least hosta
didn't send her to robert
so the riverlands joined the war against
the mad
king and it was on one of our rivers
that prince rhaegar died
sealing the fate of his dynasty
robert was a great soldier and a
horrible king whatever the case
house frey does nothing so well as
survive
when the ironborn conquered and raised
the riverlands
the phrase hid in their castle when
aegon and house tully swept the ironborn
back to the islands
the phrase hid in their castle when my
ancestor demanded their allegiance
as aegon's new lord paramount of the
trident
the freys bent the knee from
their castle perhaps then we should not
have been surprised when my father
lord hoster tully called his banners
against the mad
king and lord walder didn't answer
the baratheons starks aarons and tullys
some of the oldest and greatest houses
of westeros
fought and bled for the cause of justice
while house frey hid in its castle and
waited
no doubt if rhaegar had one at the
trident lord walder would have given him
safe passage into the north
to destroy the rest of my husband's
northern army
for a fair price but rhaegar fell
and lo and behold the frey army appeared
to render aid to
our already victorious forces
many sniggered that lord walder had been
waiting for his army to come of
age having fielded it out of his own
britches
my own father named him the late lord
frey to the other lord's amusement
in many ways however lord walder was
wise
we had no guarantee of victory and had
he fought with us from the outset and we
failed
he would have lost the bridge his family
was so proud of
more pride than honor those
should be the words of house frey yet
part of me wonders if lord walder waited
not out of fear but
hope that we would be destroyed
leaving him to assume my family's place
as lord paramount of the trident
to buy the respect they've always wanted
but refused to earn
targaryen rule quieted the stormlands
for the most part
until robert rebelled against the mad
king
his first challenge came not from the
crown but from his own bannerman
who tried to join forces against him
robert struck first
defeating three armies in a single day
at summerhall
the victory cemented robert's control of
the stormlands and he was able to march
on the reach and riverlands with no
enemy to his rear
yet not all of robert's bannermen sided
with him
so barristan the bold came from the
stormlands
but as the pre-eminent member of aries
kingsguard and greatest night in the
realm
sir barristan remained loyal after
robert's decisive victory on the trident
robert sent his own maester to care for
his countryman sir barristan
who had suffered grievous wounds whilst
fighting so hard to kill him
later when the king's slayer betrayed
heiress
robert pardoned sir barristan and even
took him onto his own king's guard
house aaron remained loyal to the
targaryen dynasty
until lord john aaron joined with houses
baratheon and stark
in rebellion against mad king heiress
upon winning the iron throne robert
named lord john
hand of the king a position he held
until his mysterious death
avails isolation does breed an abundance
of honor and
pious bleating which governs their
decisions instead of foresight
like a blind man who can only guess
where his horse is taking him
i doubt john aaron had even prepared for
civil war when he raised his banners
instead of handing over his young wards
ned stark and robert baratheon to the
mad king
honor demanded and lord aaron obeyed
he'd have done the same if the boys
hadn't been the lords of two great
houses
who could field mighty armies of their
own but perhaps i give him too little
credit
after all if the war went against them
only lord aaron had a nice impregnable
castle to retreat into and he was wise
enough to take poor lysatully into his
bed to win the riverlands as allies
john aaron won then john aaron died
the reach stayed loyal mostly
my father mace dealt robert his only
defeat in the war
even if it was my father's vanguard who
did most of the fighting before he
arrived
after the battle of ashford we laid
siege to storm's end
robert's home unfortunately the war
ended before we could take it and free
up our armies to
go save the king some may question my
father for laying siege to the
baratheon's home
instead of marching to aid prince
rhaegar before robert could kill him and
scatter the royal army
but let us not forget that we had
already dealt robert his only defeat of
the war at ashford
if lord tywin lannister had not
vanquished the mad king so suddenly
our siege would have destroyed robert's
home and his brothers
and won the war for ares
but when the targaryens fell house
tyrell again
chose peace and prosperity over war and
devastation
and bent the knee to king robert
baratheon first of his
name i remember the day the lord
commander wrote my name down in the
white book
the official record of the kingsguard at
16 the youngest member ever to join
knighted by his arthur and sebarist and
valor against the kingswood brotherhood
an outlaw had decided to try his luck
against a lowly squire
he wasn't using his head so i took it
off him
shortly afterwards king aerys ii who
hadn't yet earned the title of the mad
king
took me into his service if i have ever
been happy
it was that day everyone in his kingdom
soon knew the names and sung the songs
of the king's god
i certainly did from earliest days lord
commander gerald hightower
the white bull arthur dayne the sword of
the morning
arthur dayne gerald hightower sure
if half the stories about them are true
they could swing a sword better than
most
makes their lives even more of a waste
bodyguards to the maddest king the seven
kingdoms ever saw
watching their king burn men alive
hiding the stark girl that prince
rhaegar stole away
causing a war that toppled their king
and all this
without any gold or women to show for it
stupid boogers
the only one with any sense was jaime
lannister when his father stormed the
city he put a sword through the mad
king's back rather than die gloriously
at his post
he's still here they're not
my sister elia she married prince
rhaegar targaryen
and became the princess she already was
in dorne she walked among vipers and
none would bite her
in king's landing she found herself
surrounded by lions
when robert baratheon rebelled against
his rightful king his future
father-in-law
tywin lannister ordered his beast gregor
clegane
to murder my sister along with her
helpless children
and men called the lannisters heroes
dragons conquered the seven kingdoms
but to rule them the targaryens needed a
lesser
temperamental tool when the great king
maegor saw the power of the alchemist
guild
he blessed us with his patronage in
those days we commonly
transmuted metals and other wonders
but the king was most interested in our
mastery
of the substance which those not
of our order dubbed wildfire
after the unfortunate prince aryan
targaryen
drunk with wine boasted that a draft of
the substance
would transmute him into a dragon
we lost our royal favor
then came the wise king aerys second of
his name
i was merely an acolyte when he restored
our guild
to its former glory as had his great
forefathers
he appreciated our secret arts even
naming
wisdom rasat as hand of the king
together they punished his enemies as
befits a true targaryen
during the war of the usurper i heard
whispers
that king aerys had engaged our greatest
wisdoms
for an ultimate weapon against his foe
but sadly king's landing must have
fallen before it could be used
and many of our wisdoms disappeared in
the sack of the city
victims of ignorance and envy
as ever i'd wager
the realm had no sharper minds than lord
tywin lannister hands to king aries
targaryen
or as history remembers him the mad king
he saw assassins and plots in every
shadow
heard whispers in silence and burned men
alive
but his greatest madness by far was
driving away lord tywin
the mad king then cycled through every
mistake of his ancestors
toading lords and at the end even an
alchemist
perhaps to save the crown's growing
expenses on wildfire
unfortunately it didn't save his crown
or his dynasty
you